what's up fool what's up fool podcast
what's up everybody
Felipe Esparza here the return of Martin
Moreno right here Lisa Esparza
Rodrigo Choi's right-hand man what's up
fool we're still tripping out man from
last week when we had the guy that was
who was the speaking to Lisa's dad was
definitely a surprise what did you find
out the other person was
oh well that Robert Raymond he kept
saying Robert and then I the guy I was
thinking of at the end of the show bill
my Uncle Bill
his middle name was Robert and he I
asked his son if he had emphysema he
said he never was diagnosed but toward
the end like right before he died he had
a horrible cough and he was a smoker he
smokes so much when we were on the
little boat little ferry that picked us
up behind their house and then went into
the like that Coco Coco Beach area we
picked us up at their house they're rich
and we went down into the little boat he
said no smoking and I was like man how
is he gonna pull this off because he was
like chain-smoking the whole time we
were there and then he just stood in the
back and smoked because he's paying for
it constant check out the what's a fool
podcast live on youtube.com slash ATC
alright right now what so right now
right now right now go check it out live
you guys see people like that are chosen
like they're just sent like to have
those energies that can like actually
detect some of that [ __ ] whether it's
like in the ballpark which normal people
can't do because they see the little
kids that come out talking already have
a lot of personality that they were like
a brother bill to be a prodigy there was
something before or like somebody's sold
it was like something went into that and
well what's the name AJ was saying that
he started like super young right seeing
that like scene stop is I've always
tried to see I don't see [ __ ] I reach
tomorrow
back in the day of someone asked that I
knew right away that they have what they
eat what they lack actually Larry oh by
the toys that he reads I guess they had
four kids she had no stretch marks no
nut that she was perfect though okay
marks from gaining weight on my thighs
but I never had one I had never had
stretch marks on my stomach my sister
didn't have no stretch marks from a baby
you know my mother didn't either brush
yeah like eight oh yeah some of this is
four lines yeah that's just not yeah
eight nine yeah you know what maybe
everybody's just sensitive to it you
know has the same cable
you just don't tap into it you know that
he meditates and he like clears his mind
every day to like be able to feel that
sort of stuff yeah if you're doing that
on the Reg maybe you're sensitive to
stuff as well I don't think it's just a
if some people have it some people don't
I think some people tap into it and some
people don't because have you guys ever
been to a haunted house that they say
it's haunted and you never seen anything
sure because I was at a haunted house it
was a legitimate haunted legitimately
haunted it was Erin Blair's house in
Corona and people said oh dude it's
haunted you can feel stuff you can feel
it gets cold it gets warm you can see
eyes and I stayed up all night I didn't
see [ __ ] but don't you think that if
somebody just puts that in your head
you're ready start and they got you and
you're creating it your crew whatever
the hell you create in your head is a
reality becomes a reality to tell you to
be afraid of chopped Mughal [ __ ] like
that 100% you're already afraid of [ __ ]
like that up in Catholicism and like
religion and stuff sticks with you you
know what I mean like it that sort of
feeling because you were in the rain and
you know just carry by pointing at
Amanda Municipal Market you don't be
here that matter taking there's really a
creepy old man by one magazine then I
want dr. pepper
here is that straight eyes curly right
mine it's natural
I pictured a big photo with the afro
looking like like it's wrong Daria
yeah I like nikki sixx area yeah but I
see the crime know like I don't Marie
curls right here to the side when it's
wet it just right here today huh no I
didn't I didn't I just left it look when
I leave it when I blow dried I just can
screen it out but if I just leave it
[ __ ] just heavyweight champion of
garage wrestling to get in real UFC
started right we're talking about I
mentioned it we were talking about that
we're watching now we're watching the
documentary of James Jim Carrey it's
called Jim and Andy oh that's a actors
do that but he did it good and when you
stay in the same character the whole
time yes
no morning Brando what madness I'm
currently on through the whole movie
yeah even off even off camera method
acting like he had people murder
real-life - Matthew McConaughey does the
same thing from what I hear like I'll
call you your character name he won't
call you your real name I'll even when
the when it's a camera break yeah he'll
call you by your photos or noise you
have a small room is doing that
background number 8 I knew that happened
with tears how to tell the story wrong
he's all yeah man I'm so I'm chilling
right I'm in my teens Hornets game and I
look out the corner of my eyes it was
okay what's going on ray he's Aldo
we had a basketball game man well we
were which you're gonna have Ray Ray we
out here we gotta stay in character ray
brother get a beer something relax let
me get some bills for you
yeah probably in here you know it's even
crazier Silent Bob is after the movies
over [ __ ] that stay in the
character well that happened to
what's-his-name cuz he got so deep he
had to send him to read to like their
Carrie no not carry the tooth that play
review Stanislavski the doors they gotta
play Jim Morrison Val Kilmer they said
that after even after the character he
they he was like just let it go
he just let his sponsor go and he was
just hanging out in at the way stars all
over the place all over London and [ __ ]
just partying his ass off as as in as
that character now now here's a crazy
thing about Morrison is that did you see
no one here gets out alive the
documentary no no I think I did so did
you read the book so so so that there's
a slaughtered Indians on the road when
he's a kid he's on a road trip with his
parents right and he sees this Native
American family that's dying so yeah so
it's so they're they're all dying right
and he's the last so he's a little kid
and he's the last one to see the
medicine man that he takes his last
breath as he sees as he sees the little
kid little kid Jim Morrison right and
supposedly in that tradition the
medicine man when he was on his deathbed
he'd be with the elders of the tribe
passing on all his wisdom and all his
knowledge to the next medicine man right
so supposedly all that [ __ ] went into
Jim Morrison's head and he and listen
Jim Morrison did a lot of LSD a lot of
peyote yeah and so if he starts
believing those traditions like I said
earlier if you believe it in your head
it [ __ ] happens bro so if Val Kilmer
did everything to get into that role
there's no way he didn't go into the New
Mexico desert take peyote and start
frying Jim Morrison died solo right so
that spirit was just wandering around
could it be that the
fools out there are Niall ated and the
spirit possessed him and for a long time
this mofo Berta I've got the spirit of
that Indian dude that Jim Morrison have
no wonder they stopped running his Mark
Twain show cliff we brought two slaves
I just think elmer has some issues I
think that Michael Douglas when they
were doing a horrible lion movie put him
to a side and put him on check and turn
listen man you're cutting up production
a lot of money get your [ __ ] together
get your [ __ ] together I see a metal
more lying hard I guess I don't know the
horrible movie and he disappeared pretty
much after that Matt we didn't see him
get your heat all [ __ ] up ya know
Kilmer yeah Doris was before he yeah way
before we was in the sixth grade yeah I
remember that I remember I've seen what
he's getting a blow job in the elevator
I was wrong with this fool he's getting
a blow job but in hee hee in hate he's
he doesn't have any lines does he yeah
yeah yes my memories arguing with the
wife
I had a horrible Super Bowl I felt like
he had no lovin any coaches my first
scene is when he's looking up at a lady
and he has a fake ID and the cops are
right there and she's looking up and
they ask her is that him and she goes to
tell him with her little hand to leave
at this the other phase like pops hey
bro he takes off his games nobody right
dude your memory is [ __ ] amazing but
they also have in that movie remember
she was cheating on a movie yeah yeah my
favorite part man is in that movie when
they're at when they got everybody
together and they were eating others
heat on them brother they're watching
them then they watch the cops and
they're telling their man listen man we
have enough money go through this job
and then he telling that guy what's the
name mom Tom Sizemore Italian I miss him
you guys you got money put away you got
money to take your kids in college you
know you don't really need this you know
you don't you don't need this action you
know and he goes I mean you go for me
the action that's poor that's what I
live for
the action is the risk you didn't give a
[ __ ] about the money you know that they
give that [ __ ] rush dawg I'll pick
the run about kill money the money bro
you say I need this because the lady
just a driver boys [ __ ] up for ya but
you know what [ __ ] scene was bad ass
cuz Robert De Niro could have walked
away now cop but he went back and cut
that [ __ ] biker dog for my favorite
party boy when he grabbed that
dishwasher and goes listen man thirty
seconds you wonder what you want to come
here in or out and he [ __ ] throws
that [ __ ] tower no [ __ ] grille and
dies bro oh yeah because remember that
flows being a dick to him is when you
get out of prison you're on parole and
they're all [ __ ] punking you for your
pay and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
though that little kid from
[Laughter]
happy holiday happy holiday people happy
Thanksgiving hell party man have you
ever had a Thanksgiving at your house
where you [ __ ] took our the cars in
and got a lock port and didn't come back
in Calcutta this mother a or you were
gone for Thanksgiving our do it by my
mom's my mom's [ __ ] God son when I
was a little child is mean approach this
[ __ ] got annihilated broke down
on the heels in his 20s
and he stole a turkey bra he stole I
guess he got hungry or some [ __ ] bro he
stole the [ __ ] turkey with the whole
[ __ ] that you cook it in yeah the
leftovers the name this [ __ ]
took all the leftovers bro but the whole
thing with I never propped up by here
braised leg or knee now I'm gonna buy
you a whole dish set no other words drug
addict right there yeah bro so it was a
crazy [ __ ] he had a van he got
in trouble one time because they seen up
with ambulance bro like he was on the
freeway an ambulance was going and he
[ __ ] got behind it I'll be totally
not bro
you know were crazy in the [ __ ] sense
where's he at now don't getting sava bro
I haven't heard from him in years
are you serious track of the [ __ ] pie
sauce but I don't know when like I got
[ __ ] up for Thanksgiving of course you
know
I got mad at your house and just to flip
everything over no bro a little white
boy in that video now did you hell yeah
it sounds like you bro but I can say
this story any crime
for a third grade or for third grade we
made our line for Thanksgiving and we
made turkeys and we like God or whatever
right but we made a little cute little
centerpiece placemats
no tablecloth table that table mats
table mats right placemats
it's lace mats yeah so fool I made one
bro we are made well we never ate it
placemat ever bro we never put no we
never ate forks our Forge never came
together you know they just threw it at
you we never had like a napkin I didn't
have a setting like so I brought the
[ __ ] apron and then I told him we're
about to eat
I said well hold on I gotta get
something and I will give my placemat
my dad ripped their dog oh you ripped it
in pieces why just to be a dick that's a
thing that don't be bringing trash to
the table he don't know what it was yeah
you know we were a colored boy he didn't
give me a chance brother a presenter to
hold were you bro third grade though bro
I forgot that she that's traumatic on
those are eating cook the crying bro
everybody laughing god damn they were
laughing sorry though
sorry and then you flip [ __ ] over now
how did Ambrose what happened
crazy I was angry and in my devil you're
mad
turn up cry never brother laughing bro
like one at this point
kill them break those fingers my brother
like this you know what parents do some
evil [ __ ] to you dude my dad used to be
a but not been your dad but dude like no
no they don't really know it's not that
they don't know about all that [ __ ] I
mean I mean it's not like you mean but
as you hear manipulative alcohol this
place Matt none of the kids had a place
man [ __ ] get that overall [ __ ] no
this is how [ __ ] up for everybody be
cool how [ __ ] twisted my dad's head
was he'd get wasted bro and he'd be like
okay yeah memory for Manuel my pal I'm
gonna kill myself right and then me and
my sister would start crying in surprise
and we'd be holding this leg right and
he'd be dragging us bro and he's [ __ ]
walking out the door wasted brokaw so
let us here we'll draw that you baby bro
and so he'd leave bro and made my sister
be like a pro first grade second grade
some toast incisor little like call me
Tony birthday me aa little toe big toe
donations
openness hey we've got a kid were you
there at that time you like you're happy
right just knows I was a little very
very in like into the awkwardly social
bro like when growing up growing up like
as a little kid you got to figure by my
parents were immigrants they never my
mom never left the house I'll do this
book you work hard hard work this ass
she liked his ass off drank his ass off
it like literally every day drank and
got up no hangovers every day every day
my mom was she didn't speak English
whatsoever she was illegal for many many
years so she wouldn't want to leave the
house so there was a lot of like a lot
of fear in the in the home type of a
thing like I know not as much of real to
this Punk to that and so when and I so
when we must have been little because he
kept pulling that same stunt about my
bro he just said anything he wanna kill
him no bro and then one day like
eventually it was like eventually dude
it got to the point where you're like
you know what [ __ ] get it go kill
yourself [ __ ] how old you evolve by
that time I was like already like in
[ __ ] sixth grade fifth grade math tip
wish my mom would be like she's a
performer this [ __ ] bro one day
he left right and when it came back I'm
like a man but you were gonna kill
yourself and it goes I stood look at
parcel this is what happened may have
intended freeway through my storyline
you asked no he said he threw himself
over in the freeway and all the cars
nothing he goes one car stopped and he
grabbed me and he said what are you
doing estas haciendo and I told him my
story my Tondo and then they said get
all Tennessee hoes yeah I have kids I
have a wife and they told me go home go
home to your wife and kids and I'm
looking at him [ __ ] nobody stops on the
freeway bro you're gonna be [ __ ] toast
your mother so come back tomorrow
it was like after that he realized all
this [ __ ] ain't working no more but when
he was I don't know what it was bro like
if you have a traumatic childhood oh
dude he did bro my dad um he was born
with polio in 1931 and to a family of
like 16 kids so they really they thought
this [ __ ] ain't gonna make it
they literally put him out in the barn
to die and they're not gonna waste the
food on this [ __ ] so what his
his left one of his legs I don't if it's
over the lead it was literally this this
thin was this then and and and was
higher than the other than the other leg
and so they just put him out there
pretty much to die his older sister felt
bad the oldest one and she won't make
food into the into the little where they
kept the chickens or whatever the [ __ ]
it was and if Cora
yeah whatever the [ __ ] and she'd sneak
food that leftover she'd sneak him into
this [ __ ] Rock right and the
[ __ ] survived and they'd look in
and they'd be like he's still [ __ ]
alive but the [ __ ] but they didn't know
that she was sneaking food to him and
then he survived I think his dad died
when he was like seven years old and so
his older brothers would beat the [ __ ]
out of him that was back in that they
were you know there was it was Mexico
but only Mexico were they from a small
town in Sonora Cagayan and she's very
young and he left and he they moved to Y
Mars and I think when he was like maybe
12 or 13 he got into a shrimp boat and
he started working on the boat and he
took off he ran away and took off and
was like when people say were you raised
by sailors he was literally raised by
[ __ ] sailors you know his most
formative years were with [ __ ]
sailors so yeah so that's a traumatic
childhood I would say you know so I
think when he like wouldn't he would
provide a roof over our head and food I
think he felt like [ __ ] you got
way more than I had what are you really
what do you want what we must get income
I'm giving you all this like I'm giving
you all the tools to succeed we landed
in the hood you know he landed in hood
but he had no idea that it was a hood it
was a hundred or a thousand times better
than the place that he originally came
from so yeah I was [ __ ] he he had a
crazy cat damn child that's brutal
yeah yeah I mean I mean to [ __ ] bring
down but goddamn come today but yeah the
[ __ ] was raised by sailors he
was a [ __ ] story he was a [ __ ]
stoner alcoholic just drank his ass I
remember being a kid and he'd give me
beer like we were drink were that we'd
have keggers in the backyard when I was
in high school with all my friends and
he'd be partying trying to hook up with
my homegirls [ __ ]
he probably didn't have any um he had no
example of somebody loving him like a
parent so he had no way of knowing how
to be a parent either and though too you
know for the most part right and I don't
and I don't bite or like I'll do what
I'm supposed to do but utilitarian more
you know 100% and see I didn't realize
any of that like in retrospect now I
think back like he was a bad
[ __ ] yeah I get the fact that he
survived that much and and went through
it and was able to [ __ ] come here to
another country learn the language and
be as successful as could be as an
immigrant I'm like that [ __ ] you
know he had [ __ ] balls and he had
Drive and he had determination but I
back then I just looked at him like [ __ ]
this got that drunk you know like [ __ ]
yeah a lot of immigrants think it's hard
now I think it was harder back then dude
it's in the sense that they [ __ ]
weren't really communicating with the
mainstream or no no that [ __ ] was like
mad subculture this an émigré it's
always been tough for immigrants I think
back then it was tough it's tough now
it's there's always been an
anti-immigrant sentiment you know and
before us when the Irish got here there
was a [ __ ] anti [ __ ] sentiment after
like amnesty in which a lot of [ __ ]
pie said put the pointy boots on in the
hats and they didn't give a [ __ ] if they
were legal or not before I remember a
lot of people were afraid afraid they
wouldn't come out the [ __ ] dobro they
were like a [ __ ] you want to go to the
movies no no no last week the [ __ ]
media showed up and took 30
[ __ ] took 40 actors they used
to pick up [ __ ] drag back then
back there we'll just put yell at me
laughs dog okay bro bro we'd go to the
others together prepare a theater
college theater or Granada and
Wilmington right the pomegranate theater
right and we've got nothing but max hey
Wilma Rio is San Pedro ha San Pedro
[ __ ] Harbor City everybody's the
world
West Side wheel muscles East Side weed
muscles arrival brawl they fight what
everybody invited to her others there's
yeah there's a lot of fun in fighting
there um but but um what was I talking
about the pomegranate Ranade
there was [ __ ] that would show
up with like a spotlight bro the cholos
will show up with a spotlight and those
fake sirens bro they load their dicks
like their dough and they be La Migra
and then they put the [ __ ] bright
lights bro and everybody would scattered
like a cockroach bro and bro I was legal
and I'd still run with the Python say I
desire everybody run you know like [ __ ]
I gotta run to it what's up fool why in
the [ __ ] they don't tell me that the new
Terminator with Mexican dog Oh
that [ __ ] walks you know bro
he's chasing uh he's like a whole new
story man he's chasing a new John
Connors wanna Connors I know life even
she the new leader of the resistance
Wow they they anything [ __ ] deport her
was the Terminator the about to save her
I'll see now I'm gonna go see The
Terminator
Ross tuned out he walks down walks into
the vodka deportation when they have
everybody are the biceps and start
looking for her and start stabbing the
[ __ ] of all you know that crazy scene
in Terminator one we killed all those
cops yes the same [ __ ] happened in that
movie bruh with a [ __ ] Border Patrol
Wow and only that dude this [ __ ]
can make himself into more terminators
oh I want to see this easily yeah let me
barb I heard earlier but it was a good
movie but bro
I knew something you looking for me
there bomb they work okay they
terminated bomb the first door they came
up I cried a story why they've movie
bomb James Cameron was fighting with a
director Tim Miller I guess you do he
directed and Deadpool one okay yeah and
then he left that movie because Ryan
Reynolds Jim Carrey that the Japanese
he's [ __ ] Andy Kaufman through the
whole movie bro yeah everybody off like
[ __ ] just showing up in the middle of
the night doing crazy [ __ ] to people the
director told him Melo's what
Melo's for me told him j-jimmy you need
to talk to Andy yeah yeah yeah I saw
that whole document reload okay - for
what I say thank you I'm gonna get rid
of them no no no the greater them I need
to just send them to settle down that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah he was at a party
that there was just a side party and
everybody came up to him as Jim and then
and he'd say you me you mean me like
they would say something about Andy he
said you mean me
but slightly he was he was at the beach
meditating clearing out how to play the
role and supposedly and he came into his
consciousness and then started talking
like a lot of the family drama as well
that had been going on
ended up getting resolved and [ __ ]
put out put out during the filming with
like the the people the survivors from
his boss around and around dude they
were like they were yeah they they had a
lot of input to say this is what this
[ __ ] life was about but he
they've dealt with him as if it was Andy
come back to life and they [ __ ]
talked about old wounds and this
[ __ ] addressed it as mean sounds
[ __ ] crazy but you know what he's on
a whole nother level
he survived able to take my devil that
fur kid please man bro
we live we will get most people put in
Wilmington ghost town yeah big big
shout-out to freakin uh Wilmington dude
you know its heard but [ __ ] it bro it
was a great place to grow up a man just
do it still hurt near Willowbrook or the
same area no that's done the way down
Wilmington Avenue
so Wilmington Boulevard woman's and
Roman are different also gonna say you
were talking about a show all these
we're talking about Jim Carrey have you
guys seen on [ __ ] Netflix a show
called comrade detective comrade it's
Russian show it's what's that place next
to could not hear coming each was she
from the Romania Romanian Romanian is
based in Romania and Jamar fresh air
remember in the 80s when you had like
Red Dawn and all these movies that were
propaganda like here come the Russians
we're evil and we gotta [ __ ] save and
[ __ ] your games like yeah all those
shows were like it was Red Army Red Dawn
yeah all those shows so this was their
version but from a common perspective so
comrade comrade detective and so the the
[ __ ] it was a show I think it was only
like four or six episodes because the
Berlin Wall fell so there was nothing
left to do after that right but it's
like everything you saw from uh saying
how scary the [ __ ] cold warrior
Russians were they're saying how scary
[ __ ] these capitalist pigs are bro and
they're [ __ ] fighting to [ __ ] for
communism to [ __ ] survive it's [ __ ]
crazy bro they had to go through five
governments to get this thing on the air
nice and who's the dude from Magic Mike
a pretty [ __ ]
Channing Tatum he's the guy that does
the voice of the lead detective and he's
the one that [ __ ] made that made this
thing happen bro it is [ __ ]
hysterical when they start telling
people like you listen to that the West
just wants to turn all the women into
[ __ ] all they want is money like
they're looking at monopoly like [ __ ]
away to indoctrinate kids into [ __ ]
capital
Brazil was there too bro oh yeah bunch
of wraps awesome arrow bro
the show is like it's worth checking out
yes it's a [ __ ] great great shot for
shot rather watching a show at the 80s
these 80 spies it's called the Americans
aha I watched the first two episodes so
crazy man she's on murdering girl
where's this on
it's a Hulu okay no I'm Amazon yeah but
it used to be on like FX or something
yeah epics but it was it was on for like
nine seasons right yeah it's a good show
bro because they're like undercover
people raised their whole lives to be
Americans in the United States these two
Russians and they're living across the
street on my FBI guy bro what a man all
they do is fire they brought like this
guy had what he had he has infiltrated
women that work in high high places like
maybe she's a secretary for a CIA agent
like infiltrating her so much to
practically marrying her just to get her
to go inside and do other [ __ ] right
like they're married but they go out and
they'll have affairs with people just to
get into like both of them are having a
threesome with one guy whether it was a
two husband are scavenging through the
whole house bread pudding buzzing Wow
and then bro dude one was spoiled but
it's crazy because they're kids
they want the kids to be spies too I've
heard about this yeah and this doctrine
ad and children yeah and it's deep
broker like they've been around since
like the $0.60 like our civil rights
sure and some of them recruited Black
Panthers in it so they have a whole
network of gear dude it goes deep when
they get involved the Black Panthers let
me the Black Panther but like a lecture
Lord and [ __ ] like real real you know
crazy black they're there they know
everything dog and they wouldn't know
when they finally like the guy
murdered brother they took care of them
bro like the family got a kind of money
and that woman they flew her to rush i
when they found out that she was married
to that dude and she stood things that
she's gonna come back and go get or do
he never gonna come back bro how many
episodes of season two deeper three okay
you would watch like five or something
let me see the other seven dude [ __ ]
on this one but on the comrade detective
the opening scene
[ __ ] it I'll spoil it they bust they
plus these dudes with a bunch of cocaine
right and they're like what are you
doing to our citizens about this country
who do you think you are the CIA in
America who floods the black
neighborhoods with this [ __ ] evil
drug bro that's way before that's [ __ ]
in the 80s
come out until the 90s born they were
[ __ ] didn't get confirmed by real
evidence until like a couple years ago
what's his name the guy from the Mercury
News in San Jose's the guys that we're
talking about him for so long and then
finally it was validated like two years
ago I had a teacher in the seventh grade
that was talking about that but when
that story broke when that story broke
was when that the that the CIA had done
all that [ __ ] and heads rolled that same
week it was the same week that the story
broke about the Monica Lewinsky and
Clinton and the dress will have come
over come on the dress is gonna be a
bigger story all the time and
[ __ ] CIA conspiracies but but
that's yeah a conspiracy came out of
that Oliver North thing and all that
[ __ ] wonderful book called um but it's
called cocaine basically the white book
hi and it's up on I reading it
[Laughter]
was a documentary and the biography of
cocaine that's why we're okay girls
doing it bro all the way to the first
drug dealer and freeway Rick Ross is in
there too bro that that whole thing I
mean watch a few guys haven't seen a
document a movie it's a movie called
kill the messenger yes I saw do you huh
dude commit suicide
the dude that ratted on the CIA and
broke the story he committed suicide the
dude shot himself in the head twice Yeah
right
[Laughter]
ruled a suicide dog well dude look at
Barry seal when they popped them in the
end they popped him in Arkansas again
they had him playing full of coke all
actually you know the the federal
marshals had him and then they get a
call because welcome Bill Clinton was a
the governor at that time let him go
[ __ ] crazy world living it finally
caught him why for them the more and
that night and some other hidden in our
code when they caught him in narcos he
was not various yo he go ahead before
you got Kashmir man I got my get get a
jail free card and he's on the photos
blow the photo that he took for the with
a plane of Escobar greeting him and
other luggage and everything around he
go let's talk and then that and then now
I got a month later now some cartels
came some sicarios came in from Colombia
and blast to that for lab because Ronald
ray they were they released a photo and
then they [ __ ] that you don't get out
it was like who's like like a double
murder right like well this guy cover it
up and it's because they know they never
talk and everything then kill himself
nice show coming up right your show
coming up absolutely we I've got shows
on the 20th of December homie I'm doing
an all Spanish show in satis California
that's in the Central Valley with hey
that's where is that were many more than
other
that is yeah it's right by Modesto yeah
yeah so we'll be up series series yes
said it said it's not serious but anyway
I forgive me what the last day series
bro that's from the 20th of December and
then we're heading out to Iowa City on
the 31st New Year's me and hooter on the
second we'll be in Chicago and on the
4th we are in Morris Plains New Jersey
so get your freaking tickets Raza oh and
then we got that show coming up as well
December 11th December 11th out at the
Paramount with it's all Spanish show
with his sister a whole silent bob tan
Estrada and then also on the 15th I'm
doing a toy drive in espanol at the ice
house for like a you know for Christmas
Navi doesn't involve a last go the the
love child of la india maria and brown
Velasco making appearances yeah well we
had the December 10th you're gonna be
doing that the one in Riverside this
yeah oh yeah what's up for November 29
to December 1st opiate up its Berg
improv hopefully you gotta make it up
December 6 are being Grand Prairie Texas
funny and famous show with DeRay Davis
faizon love cocoa brown and Marlon
Wayans people December 10 Riverside
California all Spanish show at the life
Art Center December 13 Portland Oregon
Revolution Hall my wedding anniversary
my show up on the twelve you never know
December 17 Tijuana mango aunty who are
bodega de papel
a Spanish oh man he's these shows
awesome man after the show we gonna have
tacos said we have talked a bit for the
show actually III before I get to TJ man
but those taco were calidad
Cali December 20 I'll be in Santa Ynez
California Chumash casino people and I
want to say there's more in December but
uh
what did you want to say no I wanted to
say Santa Cruz no not yet
all right but I wanted to say that
you're shooting your special yes in
Santa Ana your Netflix specials in Santa
Ana California on January 27th and 28th
and the 27th is in English two shows
that's that's almost sold out we who
maybe have 100 tickets per show left and
the Tuesday the 28th is all Spanish
shows both of those shows those are
about half sold so hurry up and get your
tickets this is at the observatory MOOC
and they are they there will be seats
not standing room even though that's
mostly a concert venue there will be
seats but no assigned seats that's it
what's up fool do you know what's up
with the love child from rebel a school
in India Maria who she look like bro she
looks like both of them mixed together
she's all over the the Spanish TMZ type
of fetish shows so apparently you've got
mighty yak gave away a few kids cuz
there's another chick trying to start a
firm confirm she was like in a famous
band she's a singer and then they hit
her up and they said hey man laying
there Mario is your mom and she's like
yeah we'll talk about it but yeah she
gave me away in show yeah so so this
other chick came out and she was born in
India Maria she's still alive now she
died a few years back but now India
Maria was like [ __ ] she made over a
hundred movies who tells the director
she was a woman director in Mexico which
is completely a man's world today you
know and she was able to do that so--but
I mean she was huge she's like the I
would say she's the equivalent of Carol
Burnett in Mexico or close to that right
and so supposedly she gave heed my
Velasco away I interviewed her on my
Spanish podcast not the assistance
available on iTunes and Spotify
yo yo yo of course - yo yo yo with
hooter we just had Eric Rivera promoting
his HBO special super white so shout out
to the homie on screen share a love
child
I love child homie what about that and
those dudes were like nolasco was on top
of the food chain in Mexico world on top
of the world right
he made careers like if you were on
simple means he make it was a launching
pad and then it just came out not to on
simple and Domingo Yahtzee I don't know
that but uh but apparently Fernandez the
little kid he wasn't Mendes now he's
like a bonafide you know French at a
music star right but supposed like if
you got on siempre and Domingo you were
going to get launched and if you and
support so the this just came out not
too long ago where it was like people
were paying money like if you didn't pay
the money I paid you won't get on you
wouldn't get on doing that thing - huh
oh and supposedly by Ola Ola he stopped
he stopped Luis Miguel from blowing up
early on because they wouldn't pay the
[ __ ] money or he just had some kind
of vendetta again I heard he was hated
on because he's originally from Puerto
Rico
probably so who knows what it was but he
stopped him from blowing up and all that
[ __ ] came out and then it came out
there's not much money [ __ ] cuz I
think it was Televisa right was it was
gonna be I was Televisa and it
controlled the entertainment [ __ ]
industry in Mexico 100% sold by Lascaux
you know he can't come out he was
married with his family
Laimbeer Maria was married with her
family they can't come out and say hey
man we got this [ __ ] kid so they gave
her a way to the maid and she was raised
by the maid is a finance the maid or
anything they get some sort of funding
they had to have given her some [ __ ]
money they had to
right I mean so does she grew up
entirely with the made up with the made
and I think she was raised here in the
United States she ended up in foster
care in her early teens because I guess
that dad was molesting the [ __ ] kids
and so she went and testified and all
kinds of [ __ ] and then they said and
then that's when she found out that it
wasn't her dad they said well he's not
even your dad and blah blah blah and
then they told her she was like whoa
what the [ __ ] and then she found out and
she tried to hide it like I guess she
was like embarrassed of the whole thing
and she never came out and then recently
there was like some tragedy and her
family and she's like you know what [ __ ]
it I'm tired of hiding if my son was
able to die I'm just gonna say I don't
care anymore I don't care who finds out
and she put her [ __ ] story out there
and everybody's [ __ ] interviewing her
and running with it she was on that
radio show and I was new electro whole
lotta she was on that thing a couple of
times and then plus a bunch of like like
I said the TMZ's of Mexico or of the
Spanish language she's there they're all
[ __ ] interviewing her bro she you
should have her on she speaks perfect
English
that is crazy great story great story
you know like we only interviewed her in
Spanish but she speaks fluent English if
you give me her contact info and you
guys could have her on shout-out to
Superman from Hollywood Boulevard
the Superman in Superman uh-huh that
fool passed away bro somewhat gotten
worse no kryptonite full of meth he died
in been a clothing bin you know this
one's that yeah he's trying to get close
get close out like to keep warm his home
was in it and they died in there I think
he hit his head or something and just
died upside down like that his feet were
sticking up caligra bleed is named big
dude real big guys remember Gibbs from
the like he looked like a giant Gibbs
Liam Liam Gallagher
I never met him but I mean I've heard my
uncle big dude biker-looking guy he
kills in his 40s maybe yeah young super
young guys so yeah rest in peace was
that dude man
well yeah he looked like a member Gibbs
the the door guy body he look at Jake
doing very solid he looked like a taller
version of Gibbs 100 okay no no no no
that's nice
Liam Liam performer Liam's now we're all
[ __ ] he said Liam Kennedy fool stoner
Rob's best friends yeah Liam Kennedy yet
my apologies yeah this dude oh [ __ ] he
write you as soon as you see his face
when I said I've seen I've seen him I
didn't know the guy but I
yeah he was doing his thing recently
right dude everybody has not they say
that he was the nicest dude [ __ ] ever
but he's got nothing but nice things to
say hammer Adam Murray said something
fun it doesn't even matter if the guy's
a piece of [ __ ] just wait till he does
he's a nice guy ever know people dying
as a piece of [ __ ] have you ever seen a
eulogy anybody cause overall when the
Hitler died then nobody said he was a
good guy I mean the performance to
afford the Icehouse you're supposed to
perform at the Ice House his favorite
place he said so he passed away of what
I don't know well we got back on a
Sunday Leo so Burrell no or no yeah I
don't know dude I haven't talked to Sona
Rob yet but
yeah hit a heart attack we're Sydney Oh
heart attack a November 12 so there's
our little Bob what's the name homie
yes gonna Rob Tommy stone or Robbie bro
you know what sometimes I look and I
think to myself I'm [ __ ] fortunate to
still be walking around bro you know
when you see all these dudes [ __ ]
dropping before they hit 50 you know
what healthy food like what's the name
wazuli Mercado everybody we've known
from comedy since I've met you guys it's
[ __ ] freaky
that's crazy brother when he died I was
like what the [ __ ] yeah cuz he was fit
yet something went wrong with his
stomach right something pink so it was
like a stomach like but it's true man
have you ever had a near-death
experience where you almost could've
died all kinds of times just right now
[ __ ] just driving to [ __ ] Mexico
wasted brought on to Ensenada like that
time being the CETA those [ __ ] times
I had a guns pulled at me [ __ ] been
shot at [ __ ] you know some story that
was a good one I don't know if I was
there but I know the guy passed away
because every time I want to send you a
go always people that come up with the
bingo
hey my brother passed away he loved you
guys day he always talked about you guys
we're here because of him
what so you went to San Diego you hung
all this crazy [ __ ] and he cut
in line at a burrito truck and he curses
hard about this do you say we went Bob
where are we part of San Diego's to a
show afterwards and say you and I
everyone with this guy and a bunch of
dudes and he was Alberto's and I food
cut in line in front of everybody when I
was Willie no no it was a dude he was a
big shot of San Diego I don't remember
that you're all locota bro doing poorly
burritos remember that every watch yeah
mines off that was a motorcycle Harley
yeah you got it like that they weren't
feeling Willie Hubbell the way I felt
that floors took my attention dog oh you
know what I did the other day speaking
of being healthy I want on a high-class
on me didn't you write me went on a hike
over by the over by the Hollywood side
60 right 6-0 yeah he looks [ __ ] great
for his [ __ ] age and so we went on
this [ __ ] two-mile hike incline right
and this is the second time he sat down
uh once there's a bench on the midway
point and we sat on the bench for a
while but I'll tell you what bro the
first time I did it I was I couldn't
walk for like three days bro my ass my
knees hurt my calves hurt my shin hurt
everything [ __ ] hurt and I I told him
about it and you know that fools been
running on the sand his whole life right
and we went up there bro let me tell you
something the [ __ ] thing is to keep
on moving you know what I mean like you
gotta keep on [ __ ] moving bro there's
[ __ ] that just sit in front of
a goddamn you know TV all day and then
they [ __ ] wonder why they got heart
disease I know a fool that got a hip
replacement he's never done [ __ ] how old
is he he's close to 50 but he's from
sitting on the [ __ ] couch oh yeah bro
your [ __ ] deteriorate and then they
always say to the right one
[ __ ] retire they die within a
year because you stop [ __ ] bro you've
got to keep on staying [ __ ] active
bro mmm used to be on the road bro you'd
be out there exploring like a modifier
I'd be asleep and then I'd see a [ __ ]
message from [ __ ] Ivan and you
shaking snow out of trees and [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] you know you've always been
that dude that [ __ ] goes and explores
and find straight and does [ __ ] like
we're now caca and that's the
that's a [ __ ] thing bro like a lot of
[ __ ] just [ __ ] seclude
themselves and twelve and you know start
the turret dude don't you do that it's a
beginning of the end it's the beginning
of the [ __ ] end broad I realized I
couldn't exercise because of my my
shoulder now that it's better I'm back
in the [ __ ] gym and you know what it
is - a lot of people do they go like
well you should look good when I was
young in high school and those were
those days and now I'm older man I'm
raising a family
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that she ever run into
somebody from high school just recently
let themselves go although I ran into
[ __ ] buffaloes at CVS other days that
large 3 XT the long one dude it wasn't 3
X well that [ __ ] must have had to be
[ __ ] 5 X 5 X oh I could not believe
it dawg
damn I gonna play about Big Pun big yes
depressingly big you're picking out for
Thanksgiving of course - Columbus I'm
not cooking a turkey bro you tofurkey
I'm not don't like - why fool I don't
just don't like Turkey bro my make a ham
and a chicken
oh that's we gonna do yeah I'm gonna
Bryan a chicken and I'm gonna [ __ ]
cook me a chicken [ __ ] put that [ __ ]
in the oven and I'm gonna fly gonna be
enough for everybody and a big-ass ham
it's gonna be ham and chicken and my
pants ass I kind of have you get the
habit that covered up in aluminum foil
and I'm pouring it or the cat AB no I
get sprouts I got it at sprouts and it's
an aluminum foil it is an aluminum foil
like candy but I know it's can't ham
shut up what do you do with the you bros
tier with the best way to eat ham so it
have so basically you got to heat it up
it's already cooked you're just heating
the [ __ ] piece of meat up right again
you can just put it in the oven with
whatever the [ __ ] you want to [ __ ] see
those people put pineapples people put
cloves
cuz you know what this is a honey baked
ham all they do is put in a big ziploc
with water and brown sugar they bright
it with a brown sugar yeah and then you
can do it again at your pad and use you
know I'm gonna try that [ __ ] that's
problem marble
official delicious were out because I'm
gonna prime the chicken tonight I'll
probably provide in this [ __ ]
with brown sugar you do another cookie
call me mighty good no I remember your
chilaquiles were [ __ ] bomb bro you
still tearing up well yeah do it I know
I made two Battlestars people is that
what yeah bottom dude
I bought some the other it was a it was
a tiny-ass apartment right it was tiny
like little as [ __ ] when I lived over
there in this place in Wilmington right
off the freeway and [ __ ] April it was
tiny but the [ __ ] chorizo was giant
bro that's why I think it looked bigger
because the place was so [ __ ] small
it made it look bigger yes right behind
the golf course right yes over there one
day and he slept the whole day problem
hey hey whatever by the chorizo burner
having a little Bowl or something
you're [ __ ] chewing and you Jews with
that [ __ ] we're a baloney
did you see the [ __ ] illegal baloney
the pounds of illegal below it was
frozen it's our brother responsible in
Bologna Bologna
yeah well oh we won't bring over meats
from another country because they have
certain diseases and [ __ ] yeah bro
exactly yeah but they're probably making
sandwiches out of those raw cheeses and
stuff - that aren't pasteurized and then
you know and in Sonora they have these
little Chile's right these little little
circles because she's dipping she's the
kind of red that's what Coco was growing
yes I'd you touch them in your bro there
and so [ __ ] they're expensive if you
want to buy these much they grow wild
over there were my parents
good all you need is a little bit you
know this real hard but it says you just
need a little bit of cheese the penis
yeah but dude I saw the Bologna thing
and I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
bro we got fentanyl coming in here we
got coke coming in here but thank god
these [ __ ] got this killer Bologna
off the street yeah they sent those
fools in first and then they passed the
fentanyl they're killing each other
right now in Mexico for avocados
avocados it's the new green gold yeah
and me truck gun there's that [ __ ]
it's the new [ __ ] hotels to the
control of a car Oh what the [ __ ] is
weeds legal they are they [ __ ] are
and if I bug there was a crop problem
there wasn't there a problem with the
crops in Mexico there was a problem with
the water and the soil yeah okay so
there was a problem with the crops that
reduce the supply and then it created a
black market they've got [ __ ] people
at the farm with [ __ ] ak's right now
guarding but got them
avocado car approaches like back in the
day and narcos mexico card in the fields
what got this and baloney bro the new
got them tools of the trade
let's gonna be Caesar water from Mexico
has always been hardcore like that like
there have been stories of like a kid
jumping over and stealing a [ __ ]
chopper I'll tell you they don't [ __ ]
I know that coffee is protected like
that like that now too though cocoa
beans yeah [ __ ] are killing me with
these goddamn [ __ ] comments broad
average throw count is that 82 boy
protocol at 67 somebody said one wanted
to be my father
and they pilgrim for these [ __ ]
are weary bro hey [ __ ] Phillipe I
just went all Takashi 6-9 oh dude your
friends are [ __ ] waiting homie
there weren't your wonders what's up
mega man always manages to get himself
in there in the mix what's up Mega Man
Chingo Bling gonna get booked in Atlanta
at the punchline he's not in Atlanta
Mario's nobody's trying to get booked oh
I thought your man the Chingo Bling is
[ __ ] killing though right now isn't
he yeah I sent him the information for
myself
what's up fool man what I go over there
last week what Desktop an apple and last
week huh no we weren't here last week no
we had up what we were doing yeah we're
modesta way we had good sex it is said s
said series a [ __ ] crazy a [ __ ] I was
telling my mom the other day that I'm
the Santoni know the wheel Mouse cuz you
know they got the Sun Tony no they poach
I have you heard of him ya know Joe you
know what coach is right it's been
the lab right they brought it from Spain
there they brought it from Spain to
Tsakanikas yes newest architects so now
so the Santo Nino the Santo Nino
probably done a crazy rabbit hohoemi so
I said because I'd like with you know
the baby Jesus right Santo Nino right
who's Santo Nino right and so then I I
said is it the same Jesus or thank you
so it's but he's a teenager he's like 12
and so in in so in the village and they
thought the Virgin the vision the
approach is in approaches pain so pain
is a place in Spain was sitting there
with a kid right and when the Muslims
the Moors came in conquered Spain they
locked up all the Christian men and in
order to be able to kill them and get
away with it they said only kids little
boys under the age of 13 can bring these
[ __ ] food and if they didn't
have a kid nobody could visit them and
bring them food so they would starve and
apparently this kid David the women went
to go pray to the [ __ ] villain via
torture and said hey man don't let my
man died and the little kid came off of
the vide hand and walked to the prison
and his [ __ ] basket of bread never
went empty and his [ __ ] thing of
water never got [ __ ] empty and so he
[ __ ] kept these people alive so he's
the guy that the prisoners pray to the
Santo Nino is the guy that the pretzels
the the inmates pray to right and then
people got trapped in a mine homeboy
showed up and they knew it was him
because when they looked at the sandals
on the goddamn statue they were full of
mud dude and so then I'm like [ __ ] a
that's the Sun thing I didn't ever knew
the Santo Nino story but then [ __ ] on
Google you realize there's a Santo Nino
de cebú which is a place in the
Philippines and the Filipinos to this
day have the Santo Nino that one of the
goddamn explorers brought and he looked
just he's the same color as the
Filipinos so now you get the Santo Nino
they say who dressed like the Santo Nino
de Atocha but with a different color
robe and [ __ ] still running out Libya
homies and then there's a santo nino
barely a product any know the prague
behind the Santa they never thought
there was gonna be an Internet and we're
gonna connect all these god damn son
Tony knows and sure right dude I was
just like what [ __ ] so I was telling my
mom I said you know she's got
Alzheimer's and I go hey mom would you
know the Santo Nino and she goes oh see
we won't eat though he's very very
beautiful and I go yeah you know I'm a
son Tony no - and she goes I got they
put us on Diablo and I go now mom and
she they don't and Tony knows where you
are son Tony you're a Monica well me and
the son Tony near the touch-up used to
play marbles when I was a little kid and
God made me the son Tony know the woman
my mom just starts [ __ ] laughing I
sort of God she dude she forgot
everything but she still loves her
Saints in the religion she thinks I'm
growing that hell she thinks I'm going
to hell for saying that I'm a son Tony
no bro after knew that would meet that
Sonny know that will meet that homie
yeah she thinks it's platicas if you if
you go to suck a dick as you go to
fresney and you go to plutinos there's
all these pictures all these like little
drawings and all these like letters do
by hand of miracles he created like
people like miners at fell through yeah
he's the miners and prisoner he was
paralyzed he pulled him out and he they
were to go pray for him and pray to him
his wife and his kids and then that next
day that dudes walking the Santo Nino
goes up [ __ ] it's a fine now
they have like all these images of him
bro and when you see him some of them
he's crying dog is crying blood and he's
got all these gold chains he looks like
a narco Santo Nino bro he's like I'd go
chains and all these [ __ ] outfits bro
even like platinum Tejanos oh they
pimped him out the Sun Tony are you
looking about if I wanted I rode in bro
I don't know about the Ireland I know I
think also the artists in those regions
too had a big hand in creating the
images of a lot of these like in the
rent during the Renaissance very
different periods of time they had to
create the images they made them a
little brown
you make them like what if all the
stories you tell
Wow
I'm telling you dude there's a ton of
Santoni nose and they all resemble the
people of that region it's a name that
what a looper they turned her Brown in
the tonin scene there was over a hill
immense gone unseen was an obedient
there was one motto Nance right and then
the one that Solaris you're Juan Diego
right so and that and so where they
build that that the pinata Basilica that
was where they worshipped torn on scene
yeah they just don't make burritos there
yeah yeah and think about like that Bay
yeah think about what that means all
we're gonna tip it off like they brought
that [ __ ] info remember that [ __ ]
100% in culture like in this [ __ ]
that's what we're celebrating
Thanksgiving right now exactly no no and
but Thanksgivings kind of falling away
though lately you know people are more
conscious of what happened you know but
if it wasn't for everything that
happened we wouldn't be here right now
that's true that's a lot of times one of
the arguments
it's like when you they get rid of the
statues or I know I mean things change
and things in evolution of nothing that
you'd get rid of racism I think that
people just want to stop revering people
that maybe everybody should shine a
light like like Gandhi you know over
there in in Africa they took down the
Gandhi statues like I know like a lot of
it he's always he's got a lot of stuff
in his past
oh he's a pedophile - well he slept with
his granddaughter for many years nude
because he wanted to test his celibacy
and train and to himself to be more
celibate by having am i sleeping next to
temptation and I'm like [ __ ]
granddaughter's impatient it's so nasty
and she was like I think 11 when she
started sleeping with him maybe younger
and then I think he did it with another
granddaughter again but like wouldn't it
I thought you guys about this video game
you write the speedo speedo yeah
yeah the Bikram yoga holiday no no no no
you chrome guy there's another dude
brothers honey or they go this guy's
still going I thought I told you guys
the last time I was here bro
[ __ ] speedo guru this [ __ ]
bro had a cult in the 1980s and he's
still pointing strong today they haven't
taken him down the speedo
this [ __ ] guy was an a crusher this
guy was an actor he was on Rosemary's
Baby with his claim to fame right he
only had one scene right yeah and then
he ended up his documentaries on Netflix
tambien and this fool [ __ ] started at
all right not the guy that Indian guy in
Portland the Portland area I think he
might be was at the port no I don't
think it was basically took the
government over no no no no you're
talking about you're talking about a
wild country yeah yeah no no no this
this dude was rolling or yeah that was a
show oh sure yeah no this fool this fool
was like this gay dude right and he
would like say okay you have to come and
I'm gonna do psychotherapy on you right
and then he tell them hey let me know
your past and your secrets and I'll and
people will pay him 50 bucks right and
these guys were straight they were in
the pulp and and he'd start and so he
knew what their weaknesses was and so
when they'd come back he'd [ __ ] tell
them okay the therapy is gonna be more
effective if you're naked right there
and next thing you know he's boning
these guys right and then they're like
hey dude no I don't want this [ __ ] and
he's like more inside he's like okay you
have a blockage from your past that's
not allowing you to receive he was
[ __ ] all them dudes and they're all
straight bro these [ __ ] gave up
like 40 years of their life right up to
this dude and he stole his coke stolen
its a new google speedo go find this guy
but other the documentary is raping
these men holy hell it's called it's
called holy hell no pun intended
Anna and the Dubrow this [ __ ]
was like this Purdy dude he's always in
a speedo just walking around and he
touched people on the forehead and they
feel the [ __ ] you know like my mom
[ __ ] get slain in the spirit
[ __ ] well this fool was [ __ ] getting
it in Braun telling them don't tell
nobody you're the only one that this is
because I feel a connection to you like
my grandma dude and his [ __ ] bowling
all these straight dudes and telling
them not to have sex with women and and
and they listen to this guy they all
[ __ ] work for this guy they literally
sacrifice their entire life there's this
one family had three kids and all three
of the kids joined the [ __ ] cult bro
the dude they say that he was a failed
actor who created the role of a lifetime
he wouldn't do these elaborate ballets
cuz it was a ballet dancer and they'd
only perform them once and two just for
each other but it was like a full-on
production all these [ __ ] production
things that he did and now he's in
[ __ ] Hawaii recruiting at yoga
studios [ __ ] are still [ __ ]
hooking him up bro so they never got him
on rape charges or anything never
watched never he never the dude because
the dudes did it willingly you watching
great shows brother every while I'm here
watching reruns of we take two times
nice great [ __ ] show that really give
me a Firebird dog you know kid you like
cars you want a nice car I did I I you
know what when I was a kid I think about
back to being a kid I just wanted any
car homie I wanted large I just wanted
to drive and they'd be like oh no but
that's a shitty cut there's no such
thing as a shitty car if cars a car you
know you just want a car you know I mean
now kids don't want to drive anymore
[ __ ] are like yeah [ __ ] that
yeah Isaac is 15 and he has no interest
in like taking his permit test I was so
weird couldn't even wait
dude no kids today they're like I'll
[ __ ] it I don't want to they have
different priorities
they say that priority they say I think
they say that Millennials travel way
more than baby boomers and Generation
Xers combined they spend their money on
that they don't want it like an
apartment and a car and of this they'd
rather take their money and get
experiences out of it yeah that's why I
think the suburbs are gonna eventually
fall away and people are just gonna want
to live an apartment ground end up with
that speedo guru in a communist bra dude
I saw this guy and I'm like you know I
could start a call thing easy [ __ ] yeah
let's start a call the cold without
caste bro we look pretty goddamn leader
cult leader rich look at us we just put
some goddamn [ __ ] robes on II vamonos
Kavanagh and start guys in a compliments
all day the world has taken over his
mind there you go he's a nice man I seen
him draw I don't know he's drawing but
bras bro this [ __ ] would tell
people they had to get the knowing you
have to get the know and then he take
him into the woods bro and all these
people would be like he'd be like this
chick was like I was ready yeah this was
girls and guys in the car [ __ ] and she's
like oh so I had done everything I've
done everything and I was ready to
receive the knowing and then when I went
to have my meeting with him he looked at
me and he said you're not ready
[Laughter]
but when you watch it you're gonna die
bro anything she's not ready and they
just wanted the knowing bro they extract
their knowing now he wasn't interested
in girls he was just interested in dudes
bro he was welcome to join he's a guy
the pervert neighbor from our family guy
I read a gay neighbor I told you that he
was always interested in hanging out
with the teenage boys he would tell
people people that wanted to leave he's
like I had a conversation with arias and
he jinjo this year he told me that it's
I don't know how to say this but your
time is your it's time for you to die
but I I spoke to God and we made an
arrangement and as long as you're under
my tutelage you'll be protected but if
you go out there I won't be able to help
you you're just gonna be vulnerable to
the world so as long as you stay here
and do service to the whatever the [ __ ]
they were called you'll be okay dude
this guy believed that you couldn't
Google diamond [ __ ] but I would never
fall for that [ __ ] you never know homie
do you guys fall for that [ __ ]
but it takes allocations have you filled
out in the airport yeah but it takes
time it happens overtime it doesn't
happen right away like that you get
brainwashed and especially if you're
sent over there young if you grow up you
grow up in it it's all you know it's way
easier to be brought in and you know
yeah that's so the guide there was a guy
who had gone to film school and he had
just graduated and this is the 80s right
and he comes out to his mom and tells
her that he's gay and the mom kicks him
out of the house you know there was no
[ __ ] you know no support back then
and so she kicks him out and the guys
like lost and then he ends up finding
this dude and he's documenting which is
phenomenal because he's got all the
footage from [ __ ] 85 until he
actually confronted him in Hawaii but
he's got all he's the one that made the
documentary and so you see like all
these people that were former members
telling what they recollect so you see
them now but you also see the footage of
them when they were young and there was
one dude and he's sitting there and he's
like you know I regret anything
you know I sacrificed my 20s and lost my
30s and my 40s and now I'm 50 but but it
made me who I am today and then he just
breaks down crying bro because he
realizes that's his whole [ __ ] life
that he spent and service to this guy
right now bro bro and but this guy
documented it all he would do videos to
recruit he would do videos to sell [ __ ]
to support the cult and they would they
would say they're not a cult they're
just this this this group of people that
that found something good and that they
would [ __ ] they would train they
would train cuz after Waco had went down
and they busted them this guy got
paranoid so he'd have meetings with them
and he trained them in case the FBI
showed up of what they should say so
they would have these interrogations
these fake interrogations of [ __ ] that
went down
[ __ ] oh dude it's [ __ ] phenomenal
[ __ ] holy Oh but before I close we got
out of here but it's like Scientology
though they it's all it draws in people
who are weaker you know who are in a
vulnerable state or normals well I like
it like in Scientology they're here they
started in Hollywood you how many
insecure people are in Hollywood looking
for answers looking for something and
it's yeah guidance reaching out for
something and there's nobody here you
know they all come alone and they get
sucked into something like that but
[Laughter]
stress and the 20th of December Morris
Plains New Jersey on the 4th of January
Chicago the 2nd of January and Iowa City
on the 31st auto shows are myself in a
hooter Moreno from the yoyoyo podcast
Cora Marty no rain no calm for shows in
2020 as well Felipe thank you for having
me brother really what [ __ ] your
plethora of information on stand-up live
in December Phoenix Phoenix
December 27 28 29 and 30 first Thursday
- yeah no no yeah 9 no short 32 comment
what I said yeah 27 28 29 and are doing
31st hang well there we have a free free
day bro yes donut do so much what's up
fool